let's get to the news all right so
here's what we got
this is great from the guardian trump
ally mike lindell of mypillow
pushes martial law at white house
photographer snaps pictures of notes
near west wing visible words include
move cash patel to cia acting
interesting they say donald trump will
be replaced as president in five days
time by joe biden
trump continues to basically claim his
election defeat by the democrat was the
result of fraud
the president has now said he disavows
the violence as we get
lindell has seen has risen to prominence
among allies urging the president on his
attempts to deny reality
on his facebook page on friday the
mustachioed seller of sleep aids
wrote keep the faith everyone we will
have our president donald trump four
more years
later a washington post photographer
caught images of lindell in which parts
of notes he carried were visible
among visible texts were the words quote
insurrection act
now as a result of the assault on thee
and that's it
then it says quote martial law if
necessary and quote
move cash patel to cia acting the notes
also refer to sydney powell an attorney
and conspiracy theorist
involved in trump campaign lawsuits
meant to overturn election results in
battleground states
almost all of which have been
unsuccessful now we have the images
right here
so this is tweeted by jabin botsford my
pillow usa ceo mike lindell shows off
his notes before going into the west
wing at the white house on friday
january 15th
and you can see some things we don't
know what this is
i'll tell you right away what my my
biggest problem with this is
for all we know at the top of the page
it says hypothetical or it says
recently you know linwood posted to
parlor the following
and it could just be example text it
could be a reference it could be
fake we don't know what it is or or or
what you know what he's supposedly
talking about why things are you know
this there's redacted sentences on this
page
the media just took a picture of this
zoomed in and now they're running the
story as though the my pillow guy is
like trying to stay jakku
and that's like the narrative now it's
trending on twitter so um
i guess let's just let's just get down
to it jason
is the my pillow guy staging a coup i
mean very clearly
[Laughter]
i will say this so in the context of all
the things that are happening
and some of the crazy things that have
been said by trump loyalists
i understand why there might be the jump
to conclude that these are his thoughts
you are obviously correct in that they
do not have proof he has since come out
i think it was the washington examiner
he spoke to basically saying no these
were notes from a lawyer
now i don't know if that clarifies was
the lawyer
promoting this and you were then handing
it to the president
apparently the president had read it
they met for about five to ten minutes
and that was that you know i think it's
fair game
to point out the crazy stuff on that
sheet of paper
yeah i agree let's not go ahead and just
automatically assume
but let's also not pretend that mike
lindell has not said some crazy things
he he has he has but
can am i allowed to just please live in
the reality where the my pillow guy is
the master behind behind this coup
to take over you know and help trump
stay proud i thought i was supporting
that
maybe he has a pillow fort you don't
know of course yes
yeah wow how how uh it's it's 2021
things are supposed to chill out i
i like that meme where it's like yeah
2020 is over and six days into 2021 and
it's the viking guy
the senate building or whatever and now
uh it's it's day 15
and they're claiming that my pillow guy
is trying to and tell the president to
invoke the insurrection act
maybe maybe i mean he's tweeted about it
hasn't he hasn't he said
in the past something about martial law
i don't remember if it was martial law
specifically but he's definitely
sort of flirted certainly there you've
obviously
heard people making this exact same
claim i've seen some of these tweets
from random people
which is very odd if you're saying the
president is not
a dictator to then actually say you
should send
national guard to complete let's just
call marshall up
i i was right work i was reading about
world war ii man
because we had a comment the other day
about the beer hall push is that how i
pronounce it i'm not entirely sure
where uh in 1923 the nazis tried
staging a coup and got stopped and so
i've been reading a decent amount about
uh history i was reading about italy i
was reading about the soviet union in
germany
and i'm just imagining like if in a
hundred years some kid is like studying
history and it's like in 2021 the ceo of
a pillow company
had met with the president and like you
know and like that's the catalyst for
this
i'm reading about world war ii and it's
like they say you know hitler went
in they surrounded the beer hall he
jumps up on a chair and he fires a gun
in the air and everyone stops and he
yells it's the revolution and it's this
very dramatic
reading of history about like what
happened at this time now he failed of
course
he went to prison for a short period of
time and then it was only like 10 years
later he ended up getting elected
am i supposed to believe that history
will look back on this time
and this is what like the future
generations are gonna are gonna hear
about
like we hear these really dramatic
stories these famous quotes i mean think
about these famous quotes like give me
liberty or give me death
i would rather die on my feet than live
on my knees we're gonna have in 100
years
the ceo of the pillow company said
invoke the insurrection act
because you know cults and whatever
the quote's going to be i'm taking many
calls and many meetings all day
i mean think about it that's kind of
incredible how we got to this point
is it how is it you know what i wonder
this
is it possible that back in the day when
when these these past
statesmen and and you know politicians
when they were saying these quotes
the average person just rolled their
eyes and was like not that impressed by
them
you know what i mean yeah i just
listened to herbert hoover i think it
was the president uh 1928 he basically
served us the great depression
um man he was dry and boring to listen
to
really boring i'd rather have the pillow
guy definitely yeah
so uh i'm looking at the news right now
from the white house uh correspondent
for the washington post and he says
quote talked to mike lindell this
evening he said
lawyer gave him notes to share with
potus but
repeatedly wouldn't say what lawyer he
said he met with trump for five to ten
minutes and then he referred
to council's office said the lawyers
were disinterested
very disinterested and that he allegedly
shared this document with this
washington post guy
um and um he goes on from there so it
doesn't say
it doesn't say who the lawyer was yeah
he doesn't want to say who the lawyer
was if it was lynn wood would you
believe that
it kind of depends now yeah that's
amazing
okay you know because we have no
conclusive evidence i'm going to choose
to live in the world where the pillow
guy is colluding with trump to
you know love it no it's it's not going
to happen i mean it really is strange
how we've come to this point where
people every day seem to think there's
going to be some kind of big
move by trump and it never happens
you know i i look to some of the most
prominent and vocal trump supporters
over the past several years people like
scott adams and cernovich and they're
they're talking down they're like well
you know it's it's time to move on it
happened it's
you know what are we gonna do time for
trump to leave and things like that
and i still see people i still see posts
on facebook where they're like
tomorrow's the day donald trump's gonna
invoke
and i'm like you said that last week man
and nothing happened
why why is this why are there so many
people on the left who are convinced
that the nazis have taken over there was
one journalist who tweeted literal nazis
stormed the capital and i'm like dude
the life magic shaman who thinks is an
alien i don't think he's a nazi man i
think he's just unwell
you know why i think it is because
they've been dosing kids with aspartame
since the 80s and they're a bunch of
grown
kids thinking that they're still
watching cartoons and they're expecting
like a fantasy ending
too i don't know i don't i don't know
about all that but people
just don't want to live in reality man
no and you know let's be honest about
the social media aspect of it i mean
we tend to amplify the crazy that's what
social media does and that's why
some of us are on it right because we
are fascinated by
the lunacy and that's all that this is
now
does it strike me as a little bit more
ludacy than at least i expected
yes because even you know on my radio
show as i
talk about what happened and i call it a
riot and i say the president was wrong
i didn't think it was impeachable but i
did say he has some responsibility here
immediately you just get immediately
attacked that you're not allowed to
criticize
trump at all and as much as i don't like
the whole cult of personality
narrative and talking point that has
been used this was the first time at
least
i've noticed it just outwardly absurd
yeah it just went too far and you know
it's good to be
loyal it's not good to be blindly loyal
i think
i think many of us you know because we i
i've done
so many segments defending the president
i think it was uh
dave smith comedian who pointed out that
you want to criticize him
but the critics of trump are so insane
yeah you're forced to look in the other
direction and say no
no like you know they'll claim you know
donald trump could walk past a dog and
smile and they'll claim that he tried to
kick it or something or like the fish
thing with shinzo abe where
he he poured the food into the pond
because shinzo abe did
but they zoom in and make it seem like
he did something wrong so instead of
being able to be like
trump should do this better the media is
doing worse
you know now i think what's happening is
we're at this point where
most people most of them especially
those who had been defending the
president recognize
he's out and joe biden is about to come
in but there are some people who are
used to hearing the defense of trump who
liked it
who have kept going they've never
stopped so
for you know people like us you know you
mention on your show you criticize or
you know say things like like it's over
we we put the brakes on and we're like
well as far as this train goes and they
just went
off the tracks and they keep going
that's why it's crazy when you when you
see lynn wood getting as many retweets
as he was getting
like that's that's he was getting like
20 000 retweets when he would say things
like mike pence is a traitor and the
firing squads
like what are you talking about you know
what i mean like where's this coming
from
i tell myself it's a lot of people
retweeting and saying this is insane
because i don't want to believe no no
but these are not quote tweets
like you can quote tweet and say this
guy's nuts because i did
and then i had a lot of people respond
and say i don't know we'll see how it
plays out and i'm like
sure i guess but come on man we don't
possibly happen
i mean what could possibly happen i i
god bless the imaginations of a lot of
people and it pains me to say that
because
look i'm a republican i'm a conservative
i supported trump
i was critical when he deserved to be
criticized but i
sort of had the same position of the
other side has gone
so over the top in criticizing
everything
my natural tendency was to defend right
even in instances where i wouldn't
normally
give that kind of leverage or leeway to
to a politician
because of how over the top the other
side was it's just it's a little bit too
much it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy because we've been told by the
left for the last four and a half years
a riot like what happened or the siege
was going to happen we were told that
and every time they said that in the
past we're like there's been no violence
everyone relaxed
meanwhile there was actual violence on
the left in which they completely
ignored it
and then the time it does actually
happen and i'm not downplaying it it was
incredibly
serious symbolically way more damaging
to this nation
i think than six or seven months of blm
riots or antiva riots because of
just what it stands for but y'all didn't
say anything then
they defended it kamala harris raised
money for them it's it really
is absurd and it just feeds in to
this culture this environment that's
allowing for this to continue
i i don't think this is going to stop
because of how people are reacting
jason you made a good point before
saying how people are fascinated by
what's on social media
i would even go further and say that
they're captivated by it
and because of the echo chambers because
of the censorship efforts i would say
that's one of the ingredients that cause
that is causing some of the madness that
we're experiencing right now because
if people were able to talk through
we're able to communicate honestly
without any sensors without being put
into the dark
corners of the internet i think things
would be a lot calmer and i think now
with everything happening it's only
going to get worse because those same
ingredients are only added on instead of
being reduced
to this crap pie that's in front of all
of us the the real money right now
in political commentary the left
absolutely if
if you know if if i if i was the
griffith they claimed i was
i'd be 100 on board for biden and all
this democrat stuff and i'll tell you
what the beanie would be pink
well here yes it would have little
little ears yes no here's here's the
reason though
um if you if you say things like
what lyn wood is saying oh you're banned
in two seconds
if you say there was fraud or anything
like that they smear you they defame you
they take away your ads they boot you
from sponsors and they ban you outright
but if i were to do a show where i
claimed trump is a fascist dictator
this proves it the lindell meeting
proves there's an aku attempt and we
almost stay
vigilant and that it's russia and we
know it well
they'll promote it so it's enjoy reading
they'll they will boost
it yeah right right rachel maddow so
that's the imbalance there is money to
be made by pushing the leftist narrative
even when it's
unhinged but on the right you're banned
in two seconds thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you